hello reject nation today we're going to
talk about the um trial of uh johnny depp
versus amber heard for getting all serious up
in here had to do my classic beating to death
johnny depp impression anywho guys i don't need to
tell you all johnny depp versus amber heard trial
the defamation lawsuit has been going on where
uh johnny depp is suing amber hurd for that op-ed
piece of did amber heard defame him in that
article and uh it's been a fascinating one
needless to say a whole lot more has come out and
the conversation is about way more than just that
understandably and rightfully so but it's it's
been pretty much my like new religion is absorbing
this entire trial i believe i've heard every
second up until the last witness testimony you
know it's still ongoing uh but the when i when i
most recently turned it off which was just very
like 20 minutes ago the last time johnny depp
was testifying i haven't been doing videos
about it truth be told that i wasn't planning
on even talking about it as much as i've been
absorbing it and hearing all of it i really wasn't
planning on doing videos about it i had a lot of
friends who i discussed this just case with
in depth because there's a jury there but
we're all playing jury ourselves right now
anyone who's really following this trial as
much as i've been asked like why haven't you
been talking about it i have a lot of my own
personal reasons as to why some of you might
know that in the past i've i've tried touching
on it i just get like my chest with tightening
up i forget those like feelings of like i'm on
stage or something like my throat would it
would tie it and the the subject of domestic
violence is a subject i take incredibly serious i
really do i take it very very seriously to frank
right now the feeling i'm having is that normally
when i come on camera i want to be like all
energetic and positive but after listening to the
the last uh last bits of him testifying i'm again
left with the feeling that i keep doing to myself
because i can't stop listening to this trial is
i feel like a little bit hollow a little bit down
get that feeling like my heart just kind of hurts
a little bit i don't quite know how to describe
it i'm usually pretty eloquent at describing my
feelings and i know this is a sensitive subject
for a lot of people this subject in particular is
an incredibly sensitive one and i i completely
understand like when it comes to this subject
depending on one's own traumas and how far they've
come and overcoming their traumas a lot can be
applied here like a lot can be projected onto how
they're receiving the information and the opinions
that they actually form what's cool about getting
a trial is you get a lot of facts to work off of
instead and if you're able to kind of separate
yourself which i know is very easier said than
done but if you're able to separate yourself
and just listen to the information it might
be easier on forming an opinion i'm not here
to say i'm right you're wrong i'm here to just
share my thoughts i'm not going to do a full
breakdown of the situation there's been other
channels channels have been covering this this
situation in particular for years who are now
really covering it uh extensively and are doing
a wonderful job so if you want like in-depth
analysis breakdown of it please go and check them
out i'm here to just kind of share my feelings on
it right now as especially as someone who in the
very beginning when amber heard did to have her
photos go out of looking all bruised i'm not gonna
lie to you guys i instantly believed amber hurt
and i believed her for quite a long time without
really diving into the subject it's a big reason
why johnny depp is fighting you know most cases
with celebrities this is i think is a good point
to be made most cases when it comes to [ __ ] like
this if if the person actually did do the bad deed
they just kind of wanted to settle out of court
and just let it die down johnny depp has been
fighting tooth and nail and is now freaking so
public about it all this stuff that's happening
after so many years i think there's an element of
that where you gotta you gotta at least question
does that lend credence in my opinion it does
link line credence to the argument maybe he's just
fighting to restore his reputation so he could get
the work back and get the money back maybe i don't
have the opinion that that is the case well i know
there's a touchy subject i did feel compelled to
hop on camera and kind of share my feelings on
this for a few reasons that we'll explore as i
continue to talk when i first heard about this i
did decide with amber heard and around the time
when james gunn was fired from disney i went
on twitter and i said some [ __ ] about disney
and part of that i lumped in johnny depp
and instantly there were some followers
who immediately were like i'm disappointed in you
craig how do you not know about that like i didn't
know about anything and this was years ago when
this happened like much less evidence available to
the public years ago and i just chalked it up to
johnny depp wild superfans people who just can't
possibly see that the precious famous celebrity is
a horrible human being and this is coming from a
guy who loved johnny depp like i loved the [ __ ]
out of johnny depp the longest time i deemed him
my number one favorite actor was obsessed with his
filmography when i started to actually read some
of the things in my inbox where there was like
screenshots of court documents and whatnot going
through it i started to question you know what
what is what is the truth here and then over the
years channels like incredibly average and more
have been bringing to light so much more evidence
to show that there was a lot of lies actually
happening here most likely i believe it's been
a lot of lies i did start to find myself going
i really don't believe johnny depp beat the
[ __ ] out of amber heard i just don't believe it
i don't believe that happened it's fascinating to
see this trial unfold and it's being so massive
right now i remember when all these audios that
have been out for a long time that are now being
played in this trial are becoming headlines and
you know the titles of videos for the major
news outlets the major media outlets and for so
long people were saying why don't the big outlets
report on this why don't the big outlets share
this why don't they bring this to light one of
the good things about this trial is that it is
bringing it to light it's been slowly that the
court of public opinion has been swaying more
to johnny depp's side and then after the uk trial
even though he lost that trial he seemed to have
won over a lot of people still but then here now
that we all get a play jury along with the jury
it seems like the court of public opinion is much
more predominantly in johnny depp's favor that's
not to say there aren't people who side with amber
heard there's i'm not sure there's a lot of people
who are still like i'm waiting to hear amber herg
get on the stand i'm sure there's a lot of people
like that but unless amber heard's team suddenly
starts doing a good job a because they've been
doing just a [ __ ] job unless they start doing
a good job and b unless they pull out some some
like remarkable piece of evidence to support
their case i don't see them swaying the court
of public opinion i just don't see it happening
i'm happy for johnny depp in that regard like of
course that this situation is not a pleasant
one and it's an unfortunate one and really a
very depressing one it's good that this trial is
happening because a lot of people will say that
johnny depp's career from here on out definitely
it was already ruined and now it's definitely
ruined and that he's not going to be able to
really work again i'm hoping this does lead to
the firing of amber hurt again in case something
does happen to come out that completely flips
my opinion on this i'm on the side of like i think
amber should be getting fired from the dc universe
or wb to say the least throughout this trial one
thing it's done is really shift the narrative
you know in the beginning it was painted like
amber heard who was this you know fragile woman
who lived with this monster who just beat
the crap out of her and he's an alcoholic
and a drug addict and he's he's the one
who really was the this monster right now
it's very apparent amber heard was not the
individual she tried to paint herself as there's
just far too much evidence to support it been a
lot that can be character assassination especially
regarded towards johnny depp of how they'll try
to like isolate text messages exchanges like these
little things with and not allow for additional
context like what was leading to this conversation
why did this happen why was it said you know it
was just like did you know you said it okay let me
cut them up just move one up moving on right while
that happens giant depth a lot not everything like
there's a lot of things that obviously don't paint
him in a good light clearly there's a lot that
doesn't there's a lot of things that have been
very telling of amber heard especially though main
thing though the main thing because i want to talk
on this subject a little bit more in just a second
is like while definitely emotional abuse
was very much on display and verbal abuse
um from both of their sides i'm going to
talk about that a little bit more in a second
main thing is is like all that [ __ ] about like
did he hit her did he break her nose um you know
did give her black eyes the concussions ripping
chunks of hair out all that plain and simple
doesn't seem like it happened it's just just don't
i don't believe it i don't believe johnny depp did
that it's like having emotional and verbal abuse
in a relationship is one thing when you get all
physical like that where you're really like life
threatening to that degree it's like sure trauma
can form from emotional verbal abuse undoubtedly
it can it can make it last for years upon years
upon years the physical abuse that's the main
question at hand here i don't think he did i
really don't believe he did and i believe a
lot of the things that first i just didn't
and then over the years like i believed a lot of
this beforehand this trial is only solidifying
it even with as much new things come to light
it just really goes to show my opinion at least
is that she's light of the court i do believe she
stole that charity money she's lied about physical
assault her stories sometimes don't seem to be
consistent they seem to contradict one another
sometimes just the way like amber heard's team
is they they just seem desperate and they seem
kind of scared of johnny i don't know what's
factoring in there maybe they are afraid or they
are star struck in a way or maybe they're like
oh my god everyone's really against my client
um i'm a little nervous about it bottom line is if
they really had a good case on their hands i don't
feel like the lack of confidence would really
show like there's been some laughable [ __ ] that
really happens especially in the cross-examination
parts so when it comes back to the main case of it
all did amber her defame giant ben's article like
she has to prove that he was like domestically
violent the one piece of evidence that they seem
to really try to lean in on was that video where
you know johnny depp was even unsure what exactly
happened that day according to his testimony where
he's in the kitchen and he's being aggressive
with items you know he's like that joke about
like i abused cabinets you know in all fairness he
it seemed like he's getting pretty rough like if i
happen to stumble in to a situation like that with
any man there or even a woman doing that i'd be a
little bit scared like uh are they gonna break
some stuff right now i mean are they gonna get
violent sure like i understand that so that seemed
to be the one thing they were trying to lean in on
and they hey they don't really lean into that if
i'm not mistaken you know if you put someone in
that situation where they're at let's say like
i'm in the room with my fiance and then i start
like slamming some [ __ ] breaking some things
kicking some things or whatever if she's feeling
scared or i'm exposing her to me destroying stuff
that can qualify as a form of abuse absolutely
but then again what we're going to think about is
like context surrounding the things i'm not even
talking about why johnny depp's even doing that
with this whole video that played out it didn't
seem like he went into the room and started going
after amber seemed like he was isolated by himself
and then she interjected herself in there with a
camera and then when he did snatch the camera away
and was really pissed off about being secretly
recorded without his consent without being told
that she picked up the camera and you could
see her smiling about it like a gotchu moment
and there's just something about that additional
context that just seems off about it like she
doesn't actually seem like she was scared during
that situation he wasn't going after her she put
herself in that room with him and it's not like
they have a two-bedroom house or something like
that you know like i'm pretty sure where [ __ ]
johnny depp and hamburg are living is a pretty
big place i'm not saying it's right with what's
happening but it's kind of hard for me to feel
like what he's doing was being abusive towards her
in that moment if that makes sense i think this
obviously was a very toxic relationship and
there's a lot of emotional and verbal abuse
that's happening between them the most common
rhetoric that seems to be happening in all
these audios i keep coming out is something that i
think happens in a lot of toxic relationships when
one partner has a big fear of abandonment and they
feel like that they can't separate themselves from
a fight or an argument because they're worried
the other person will leave and abandon them
and this is the case where amber hurt has admitted
to literally physically assaulting him hitting him
physically harming the guy and admitting that she
instigates it and starts it and she has reasons
as to why she does it a lot of us already are
very much aware of that that it's like all the
evidence seems to support that she instigates she
starts it and she also traps in the middle of a
fight the mature thing would be to separate and go
let's take a little breather from each other let's
take a little break come back with cooler heads
that way we can actually try to talk this out
the other person though in the middle of a really
heated argument and that fear that trauma's coming
up in them they do something very abusive
and toxic and trap them into that situation
and think in mistaking that for like i'm fighting
for love when that's really not the case so my
point being is that obviously there's evidence of
like johnny depp not just in those text message
exchanges where some of it is just jokes and
some of it is just straight up mean and crude
uh towards amber heard there is some audio that is
out there of him saying some mean things to amber
herd directly the part of it though that i feel
like gets especially touchy though normally at
least in the situations that i'm usually hearing
about or that i've been privy to myself normally
it's gender flipped normally it's the the husband
is definitely the instigator and the one to fear
um while the the woman is the one who has to who
becomes like reactionary abusive back like when
they start fighting back after being pushed to
that certain point so while it's easy to look at
that and go they're both they're both emotionally
abusive they're both verbally abusive like the the
fact is that yeah there are definite instances
of such a case but there is such a thing as
reactionary abuse when you get to a point where
you get pushed so much to a point where you have
to start fighting back a little bit but finding
back does not mean he beat the [ __ ] out of her
and that's the part that really damaged johnny
depp's career and just a straight up lie
plenty of things that point to the fact that
amber heard faked those marks on her face even
the defense trying to use that whole thing with
like the milani cosmetics and saying like you know
she uses milani cosmetics but then milani came out
and was like you know when that situation happened
our product wasn't even on the market then so
there's no way that that was the case like so
you can't use this in your trial i think what's
happened in this trial with all facts presented
all evidence supported testimony whatever it
really seems like and this is what i believe
the whole image that amber heard was able to
successfully paint about johnny depp for a long
time the thing that really damaged his image
his reputation his career of him being this
controlling violent menace is just not true
and so i get why he's fighting again like
i said unless amber her match pulls him out of
her ass i'm really hoping johnny depp wins this
trial because we don't know what the jury will
ultimately vote you know they might look at this
and go what's the trial actually about really like
ruminate on it so we don't know what'll ultimately
lead into we don't know who's on that jury but
the court of public opinion really seems to be
in giada's favor with that being said you know
because so much of this is like a fight for optics
at the same time i think that amber heard ought
to be fired from aquaman too soon as i've had
to do this time and time again lately it seems
like replace amber just get a different actress
reshoot that [ __ ] i know it'll cost you some
money but do it because you're probably going
to lose money by keeping her in there so replace
amber hurt it's just not fair secondly there is
that narrative out there that you know a lot of
people feel like because jindab's put so much
out on his personal life things that don't paint
him in a good light but in spite of that i still
think he's innocent in the things he's fighting
for i'm hoping that after all is said and done
whatever the outcome of the trial might be within
a few years time the giant depth can go back to
doing what we all knew giant depth for which was
being a freaking awesome actor you know like i
i i remember thinking uh around i don't exactly
know when but there was a point after like pirates
or house in wonderland type when i was like you
know johnny depp just seems like he's starting to
lose it a little bit in terms of like his acting
abilities probably have like a certain hit here
or there like a really good performance here or
there he seemed like he was really losing a lot
of that spark and passion and start becoming like
a joke in and of himself i don't know how much of
his uh ability on camera correlates with his
relationship with amber hurt or whatnot but i
believe in a good comeback story and i 100 believe
he deserves a comeback and i think you know with
the work johnny depp has done in the past he's a
good enough actor a damn fine actor to the point
where i think he can get to the point where we
can see past some of the personal life stuff and
just see him as an actor again just look at the
character he's playing and not think about johnny
f the person who we saw on trial pouring his heart
and soul fighting for what was right after the
legacy that he he was building up a strong legacy
uh to leave behind and then it got tainted and
really stained by this situation where a lot of it
just seems like a bunch of [ __ ] plain and simple
i'm sorry for like what his family said how to
go through him i feel terrible for what he's
had to go through you know i do side with johnny
on this like i really do that's just my thoughts
um not really not in this i just had a stream of
consciousness with you guys thanks for being here